so the other day I was just surfing
YouTube listening to some nostalgic
tunes and I come upon a video containing
the Wii menu music now for whatever
reason I decided to scroll down into the
comments to see like what people had to
say about the music but I ended up
noticing some really weird and honestly
kind of disturbing comments so I thought
I would share them with you in this
video so this person says am I the only
one that finds this soothing like
hypnotic and I was thinking like yes
it's soothing
but hypnotic I'm not really so sure
about that but to my surprise I looked
the replies to that comment and there
were quite a few people who agreed with
him and said the same then there's
somebody else that claims sometimes I
just randomly hear this and again there
were like quite a few people who
experienced the same thing one of which
said it just melts into your mind
consuming it
we menu is love we menu is life so I
find it kind of strange that people were
like agreeing with these kind of weird
comments and then I see this I hear it
if it's pitch quiet at night except for
the dishwasher for some reason my brain
interprets the dishwasher sounds as this
music so I thought surely that nobody
else would agree with that one but I was
wrong because this person chimes in same
and I just find it strange that
something that specific would be shared
by multiple people that [ __ ] ends up
playing when you randomly wake up at
2:00 a.m. and this is the [ __ ] that you
hallucinate hearing my wii turns on by
itself
can anybody tell me why two hours later
wait a second isn't my weed dead oh my
god it's the wee spirit is possessing
its body okay can somebody what what's
going on what's the deal with this
sometimes when I'm not we can near the
wee I just randomly hear this music oh
yeah me too bro I'm crying I can hear
the little cliques
right now you all know what I'm talking
about you can make it religion out of
this yeah of course the person with a
Pokemon profile picture would be talking
about making a religion out of the
frickin way music I've had this stuck in
my head for the last 24 hours
he'll the weird thing about this is like
while this music is soothing or whatever
it isn't like the catchiest or Poppaea
STUV music it's not something that would
really find getting stuck in my head I
mean I can think of worse things to have
stuck in your head for 24 hours but
that's an insanely long amount of time
scientists believe that this sound is
the last thing a human being hears at
the point of death
could this be God himself well maybe
this guy should join the Pokemon guys
religion okay this one's just ridiculous
this one's off the charts the song is
very depressing for me some awful
memories and incidents happened when
this music played back in 2007 well
first of all let me stop you there like
I don't know what happened to this
person but if there are awful things
happening around you and these scarring
incidents are taking place why do you
still have the Wii on and furthermore
like if someone's using the Wii why
would they leave it on the menu thing in
my experience you boot it up you hear
this music for less than a minute while
you choose which game you want to play I
even have the dates of those things
marked in my wii calendar and it still
makes me sad for a bit and for some
reason I still like it like what first
of all who uses the wii calendar I can
only imagine yeah dad came home drunk
again and killed
I'm gonna go mark this day in my week
calendar again I have no idea what
happened this person hopefully it's
nothing too bad this [ __ ] song drives
me insane I have no idea why yeah
neither do I
no no no that's impossible no I don't
see behind we were finished I moved on